the problem that we're missing is
spirituality people didn't forgot about
that like no one grows up literally
being fearful of God anymore Islam did
not start with Prophet Muhammad please
get it out of your head because in
actuality we are Gods we create life we
whatever and if you want to be better
for yourself I'll tell you what I'm
really excited the dean Center is
becoming a reality
pulling the resources together making
this dream a reality a mega dawa Center
in the United States Allahu Akbar this
is the future and it's happening we've
got the location but now we got to get
the work going we got to build the
Masjid we got to build the Tao Center we
need you to donate now not for me not
for Eddie but for that Masjid for that
house of Allah that Allah would be
worshiped in we need to build that Dao
Center where people can come from across
the world and come and get trained in
how to give dawa and non-muslims income
and learn about Islam we gotta get this
done everybody donate let's do this
together it's happening
[Music]
good
assalamualaikum greens of Peace welcome
to the dean Shawn media your host and my
next guest psychology counselor
educational consultant media presenter
and much more
we've got a lot to talk about here
and you're welcome to listen in to our
conversation which we're going to be
discussing many relevant things
for Logan Paul you heard of acon why are
you talking about that maybe well stick
around and you'll find out and Michael
Jackson yes Michael Jackson too here on
the D show my brother Gabriel L Romani
not Romario Romani
[Applause]
show
[Music]
foreign
how you been
Allah is the most kind under the
mystery bro you too my brother you've
been uh have you been to Romania
recently I have yeah yeah just in the
summer in June yeah did you get to see
our brother Tate I didn't no I was
trying to reach out to him but it's uh I
guess he was still in house arrest and
he was not receiving people so so where
he's in Andrew's in uh Budapest no he's
around Bucharest yeah around the capitol
where are you from in Romania no I'm
from Transylvania from Transylvania
northern middle side yeah Transylvania
that has to be connected with uh what's
the guy who was doing the um
so how far is that City from where he's
at yeah it's it's a bit far but I've
been to it I was in in his vicinity I
was in the capital yeah what's the
latest with do you know anything what's
going on now I know he's outside of the
house arrest he's
outside of house arrest now I think he's
outside of house arrest but he cannot
leave Romania yeah he still got some
restrictions right huh yeah how is
Romania in general is how's the Muslim
population there is it growing how is
how are people are they more receptive
now since Andrew Tate accepted Islam or
yeah no doubt about it alhamdulillah
without a doubt
see these things everything happens for
a reason right Allah can guide a person
through a stop signing you know any
you stop there and you see a message on
your right side and you go you know and
you go in the message and you take it
there right uh yesterday we went to uh
play some pool at the messaged it
there's there's pool tables that
messages from the people who think there
isn't anything for the commitment so I
went to play pool and then
we entered and someone said yo bro this
this family they have this lady who
wants to who's interested in Islam yeah
so I think I spent like five minutes
seven minutes just explain the basics
that's it yeah I mean we were just
didn't plan to go out there bro like
Allah just connected that meeting to her
being there me flying in I mean coming
sorry from from Canada before from
England and
that's it that's how how things work bro
so that's how it works hard it's amazing
I mean just to sit with I would just uh
I had a a Greek brother Hamza zorcist
you know him Greek
um yourself Romanian my family from
Bosnia it's amazing every time you see
all these different nationalities colors
Islam doesn't discriminate welcome to
all is the way of life for human beings
is the solution to all of humans
Humanities problems solution to racism
to discrimination to all these
differences all the ills and all the
problems that the world is complaining
NATO UNESCO UNICEF everyone who's
complaining
world hunger poverty addictions Wars
Islam is the solution pick every single
problem I challenge everyone
go and do the research what are the 20
30 plans what they're trying to
eradicate and all that sit and think and
do some research in Islam you'll find
that there's a solution for all these
things in Islam right so every kind of
addiction in Islam isn't it uh poverty
you have zakah and sadaka all these
things for all the issues health and
yeah fasting and moderation everything
there's Islam is a solution to all the
problems yeah it's amazing absolutely
and someone sent me this and I said have
a look at it because uh AKA is a Muslim
and I had to look at and I said I mean
this can open up to a nice discussion
here right so I thought you'd be the
person who's best fit for the job you
also come from a background Christian
background at the same time and you've
been a Muslim for a long long time I
remember one of I had uh earlier shows
we did remember that it's like 16 17
years ago almost yeah something like
that a long time yeah a long time did
you have or I had long hair at that time
I think you did I did yeah you did an
attack yeah yeah okay so let's get right
into this we won't package this and um
and let's see where the conversation
goes inshallah this can be a very
educate I promise this could be a very
educational enlightening
discussion based off them kicking it off
it'll be a catalyst for that inshallah
let's check it out the problem that
we're missing is spirituality people
didn't forgot about that like no one
grows up literally being fearful of God
anymore so they bump people don't even
know it exists right they don't they
they want to believe it but to them in
their minds there's no signs physically
that tells them that religion or
spirituality is real because now it's
about seeing tasting feeling and the
five senses right yeah right but I grew
up differently and to ask you a question
before I go into the spiritual side is
that let's stop right there before we
continue on what do you think about the
first part uh it was interesting I'm
going to commend him from coming out and
even you know opening up the door to
talk about because a lot of these
programs may be people scared to even
bring up God bring up Allah bring up a
slum or any which way so uh what do you
think about this statement the first one
that he opened up people don't fear God
there's no spirituality this that any
other right I mean that's kind of
something that
link into your first question about
Andrew Tate that's something that he
said as well that What attracted him to
Islam
was he felt that like in other systems
there's no fear of God anymore right
and if you look at it when you talk to
your average
non-muslim they always talk just about
love love of God God loves you it's all
about love love will win love always
wins
when upon analysis of that statement and
confectionizing contextualizing all the
world problems you find that no actually
love is not the solution
a wife who loves you might cheat on you
a husband who loves his wife might cheat
on her love is not everything
it's fear
and feared the repercussions
consequences that's going to hold
someone actually from
moving past that level or that
you know border now love is important
don't get me wrong it is important and
in many cases it will work but when love
fails there has to be something else you
cannot rely on upon a love a bird
doesn't fly with One Wing It needs two
Wings two fly and that's why I'm says
like love and love and fear
right it's between love and fear that's
how you're going to balance it out so
yes spiritual is important and I believe
fear is extremely important because
you need to realize that their limits
you need to realize that
God can punish you God can
put certain things in your life that are
gonna cause a lot of problems if you
don't fear him so I think spirituality
today because of world religions and all
these new age religions it's all about
wow it's so nice look at
whatever you feel
it's all based on your feelings and
everyone's making up their own religion
right now everyone even though they're
claim that they adhere to a certain
system when you examine that claim
versus let's say their book
and you find that it's a it's a mix or
some kind of pseudo uh connection to
that not a real connection whoever it is
right so it's important to understand
spirituality is not only about
spirituality love and feeling and some
connection and it's about actually
knowing that there's consequences to a
reaction and at least
at least people can be honest that hey
even if you can't do it or you can't
fear God right at least don't change
things don't try to justify things don't
try to twist it around so it fits your
narrative that's it right at least say
I'm not fearing God I'm pretty messed up
but I'm not gonna change where the
limits are I think this is very
important to when you look at these
people it's kind of like a double-edged
sword actually with what's going on with
now a lot of superstars and a lot of
people who are not qualified to speak
about Islam talk about Islam for the
Youth they're like oh man did you hear
Akon he talked about Islam man whoa
right yo did you hear Andrew Taylor talk
about Islam man well you know but what
can happen is that now you might not
understand that okay they're talking
about Islam but are they an authority on
Islam No and can they lead you to follow
correct Islam yes indeed many people for
example took shahada from Andrew Tate
converting
uh Romanians open up their mind about
Islam because Andrew takes it there's so
many people including my my brother
who's not a Muslim you know the younger
one I met with them in England and he's
you know it's like early 20s now and he
started like talking about masculinity
and Islam and this and that from
undertake right but before no working it
was so hard for me to even bring the
topic that actually opened the doors
he's the one who started talking to me
about it right he's the one who start
talking before you see entertaining oh
Islamic this that and I was like okay
and I waited for like years to now start
you know and this was it this was the
Catalyst that was able to open up the
conversation however
is that enough for a person like if they
convert to some because of any of these
guys right
it could cause problems I mean
alhamdulillah I hope they convert but is
that where it ends and it seems for a
lot of people that it's like trendy now
and we have to be careful with Trends
because Andrew taking for example I'm
going to come into Islam and I'm so
attached to this personality what if
this personality messes up which is a
very very possible then what's going to
happen to me
this is the issue but hey he makes a
good point I think
Christian America Christian West
be them practicing or not practicing
atheists whatever but specifically
Christian I think they need to really
pay attention to this aspect the fear of
God I think they focus too much on love
and now it's LED them into an extreme
where they've corrupted themselves
they've corrupted their lifestyle
and they need to come back to some fear
to balance it up Islam has the perfect
balance you gave the example of one of
the great Scholars what is it the head
the love is the head the driving force
and then One Wing is is fear and fear
yeah it's a balance yeah hope and fear
and we see this so they'll say God is
love and love love love but then what's
stopping you from committing all these
sins that's the fear the repercussion
what you're talking about exactly you'll
see this like when uh when a child when
he comes home and the mother is more
merciful in love but then he's like
trampling all over her a lot of times
but then the father steps up that's
right gets him on the phone even if he's
dead not there but just hearing his
voice fear kicks in right that's right
and this is the balance that Allah God
has created and God is not love God is
the most loving God is the most loving
God is not a loved one that's where they
make a mistake because they think God is
love God is this what does that mean
like when you unpackage that what
exactly what does that mean right so God
is the most loving this is an attribute
but also God is the one who punishes
right and God is the most merciful and
God is the most this and there's so many
99 beautiful attributes and names that
we encourage people to really look into
which is a beautiful thing yes so they
really understand God they don't make
just these statements well God is
love and then other people say God is
hey Tau can we create it uh you know uh
you know what you call hell how come
he's going to send people's hell he
hates people he's hate right it's
horrible and people sleep well like God
hates you all right don't have signs but
God hates you and stuff like that it's
you need to understand who is God that's
why theology monotheism to heed what we
call Akida is so important you know it's
literally answers the question to that
Maine
question that has I guess you know has
been around for the longest time like
who is God what is God you know
philosophers human beings everyone
whether they like to believe or not
atheist agnostic whatever everyone has
it in their brain they discuss it they
debate it they write books for it or
against it it's the most
talked about Topic in the world
God because that's how he created
everyone feels it whether they're
against it or for it it doesn't matter
the fact is that that's what concerns
them the most yes
let's go ahead and continue on so we got
that out of the way we got this one so
you're already learning something the
correct balance here love fear and hope
you're in between these no right you
don't go to one or the other that's it
the bird's gonna crash exactly and they
represented it so if I woke up you know
as a Muslim I had to go to pray every
Friday with my pops it happened it was
not a question you had to go do it today
you have a choice
you know like my wife she's Christian I
never forced her to convert
because in the way I was taught in
Africa
I mean Islam is an extension of
Christianity
everything we actually believe all the
same things we just don't believe in the
Holy Ghost that's the only thing but
everything else is all the same same
Commandments same stories Jesus is a
prophet we both we all believe the same
right the only problem was that
you have people that okay when you go
into paganism and you know worshiping
statues and everything else we just
don't believe that there's no one or
anything higher than the most high which
is God and no man should ever be looked
at as God himself we are all Messengers
of God we're all Messiahs to our own
extent and so that's the conflict that's
the conflict with Jesus we don't believe
that Jesus was God in man's flesh we
don't we just believe that he was a
messenger of God as the Messiah so we're
not that far off right you follow so it
it becomes a situation where there's so
many different religions now but when
you think about it
we're all going to the same place we're
all literally worshiping the same
you know God we just translation by
language or by anything we just call
them something different but when you
really look at religion we all have the
same Commandments we all have the same
stories it might be told by a different
person or a different name attached to
that story but the story don't change
maybe the characters may change from a
standpoint of the name they call them
but in actuality you know my grandfather
told me something that was super super I
think you can maybe understand why I
wanted to discuss this now this is uh
because there's a lot to unpackage here
right there's a lot to unpackage yeah
um there's some and again
you know I would I would commend uh Akon
for even talking uh representing he's a
Muslim but but there's some things here
that we can adjust correct what do you
think um let's start from when he's
opening up uh so he said something about
on the long lines of um
this one as as as Muslims I go to only
on Fridays so Christians want something
most of them on Friday Islam is an
extension of Christianity right this is
the first problem we believe in
everything except the Holy Ghost so
there's a lot to unpackage here I mean
uh you're not oh yeah so what do you
right so the big mistake is that Islam
is not an extension of Christianity
Christianity is a deviation from Islam
Islam has always existed so think about
it as a
from the beginning of time when God
created
the angels He created him to be in
submission to the Creator without any
ability to fall out of that okay there's
no Fallen Angels there's no they don't
make mistakes they've always since they
were creation they've been worshiping
God
that it basically means Islam
then God created you know obviously the
jinns are there which are the spirits
and then the human beings were created
okay the human beings and the spirits
have the choice the Angels don't have
the choice okay the angels are Muslim
Muslim means the one who submits to the
Creator okay so think about as like
to Allah belongs the best of examples is
just for maybe for the sake of argument
as this continuous line okay there's a
beginning
okay when God created
let's say human beings and Angels before
that and the Jinn
and the system that he accepts from them
is to be in submission
okay and that line continues
till the day of judgment
when everything
perishes except for
Allah because he is the one the
beginning the end the first the last the
one who is not created
you know he creates he's not created
there is no one like him
that's this lie in this line that's
Islam perfect
the most beautiful the most no one can
ever
you know come up with something like
this because it's from the Creator
with time there's these side lines that
have
ramifications from it okay and these are
the deviations and that's what the
process him drew a sand a Line in the
Sand and he said this is the petal you
know through the straight path is then
he drew some lines at this shaytan this
is the past of the devil
right and I know people get upset
they'll say are you calling Christianity
the path of the devil well in reality it
is that
because it is such a deviation from the
truth
to work to which God says in Surah
Maryam in chapter 19 and I encourage
people to read that chapter 19 the
chapter of Mary
the mother of Jesus not the mother of
God the mother of Jesus
where God says that by the statement of
saying
they say Allah has begun a son
that this is a very very major statement
that this the sky is about to break and
the Earth is about to split
this is not something like oh yeah it's
just right so I know people get upset
but you know in the end the Christians
they believe the Muslims are going to
help isn't it so don't be upset you know
we're just discussing right we're just
debating yes you believe that Satan is
misguided us and we're going to hell
right this is the path of Satan so don't
be upset if we say the same thing to you
right the question that people have to
ask who's right
who is correct so this perfect line at
deviations all the religions
Christianity from Christ Judaism from
Judea Hinduism from Hind
and taoism from Tao always related to
something Islam is the concept of
submission
for what to achieve peace to have that
inner peace human beings are always
looking for some kind of
inner self-actualization
and you'll never achieve that until you
follow this beautiful straight line in
this straight line there's different
stations so the first station was Adam
then Noah then other prophets Abraham
noise Moses Jesus Muhammad is the last
station okay before the day of judgment
okay all of them said the same thing
one God
one God there's no one worthy of worship
different rules times were different
things you know this is normal clear
but there was always one constant
God is one never did a change so anyone
would change these things they basically
deviated from that beautiful perfect
straight line
is this straight path
and anyone who went away from it they
deviated they're wrong they're
subleaseitan it's not me this is what
the process these are the paths of the
devil don't be upset you should be
worried
you should it should make you want to
listen and do a bit more research to
what we're saying right now don't take
don't believe you and don't believe me
why should they believe us I actually
asked them not to believe us but
consider what we're saying enough for
you to go and do a bit more research
such as for example
read the Quran right such as watch a few
more Dean shows such as maybe read this
book such as do a bit more research
maybe visit your local Masjid and talk
to any mom talk to a Muslim that you
know do a bit more don't just oh brought
this guy spoke about Christianity look
at this guy let's cancel them or no
think use your brain we're not here
with malicious intent
to insult you oh this is these Devils no
no
to make you worried we care if we don't
care who cares we don't have to do the
show bro we can go and have food and
chill and relax why you waste why you
try why are you going you know people
don't understand that we want to guide
them we want to help them well guidance
from Allah but we want to help them we
want to give them the message
so keep that perfect line I challenge
everyone go study from the Bible from
whatever you always find
that monotheism and you'll find that
people deviating their differences and
their systems were always the paths that
have gone away so Islam is not an
extension of Christianity a Christianity
and all the religions that you know that
exist is a deviation from the path the
straight path Islam did not start with
Prophet Muhammad please get it out of
your head please do a better wish it
never stops it's a concept it does it's
not [__]
there's no sorry I know some of the
orientalists try to call it mohammedism
in an attempt to try to equate it to
Christianity Judaism and all the other
things too because they knew that people
understand the Islam is a concept where
you know we're in trouble people are
going to leave and people indeed when
they understand that Islam is a way of
life in a system they do leave their
systems and they come to Islam how many
people convert Islam be them rappers
beat them Scholars be It Gerald Dirks be
it Lawrence Brown be it you know
academics you know you don't see a
Muslim scholar converting to Buddhism or
something like well look you don't find
it yeah you don't see it converting to
Christianity maybe there'll be one an
exception here in the whole thousand
years or something like that but look at
the history how many of the top Scholars
and theologians
who convert to Islam recently there's
one upset of that one priest
I think it was in America
was it from the Catholic or the Orthodox
you know Parish Church big big huge
thing you know what I mean
you talk about the um yeah the big
Bishop yeah huge and not there's not one
it's not exception how many how many of
them this is the repeating occurrence
it's not just a one-off it's not a
one-off yeah people need to consider
yeah so don't take things now to the
heart a lot of time it's like you're
about to get the injection it hurts I
mean and that the medicine is is in
there so look at it like this is the
truth being delivered evaluated uh
investigate it don't just reject it
right away just because you've invested
a lot of emotion it's kind of natural
right yeah when that wears off when the
Motions settle down just think Ponder so
this is incorrect we're trying to help
our brother Akon are we helping them out
so next time you can give better dawa so
it's good that he affirms that he's
Muslim yeah but then as I say it's a
double-edged sword because now people
are thinking this is Islam and trust me
people are going to listen to him
because he's cool and this is a huge
problem yeah and they're not going to
listen to sometimes to
a scholar who maybe is not so cool and
he's stuck in a certain way the youth
are gonna listen to him and we're like
yo bro Akon said that Islam is this you
know we're all cool we're all the same
just different characters the story is
still different but it's all the same
it's not all the same so that's an
incorrect statement very incorrect that
uh Islam is not an extension of
Christian uh Christianity and the other
part that we believe in everything
except the Holy Ghost no that is not
correct right there's no there's not a
difference of opinion or this is no this
is mainstream this is what you're
talking about around what we're talking
about this is like yeah the whole Holy
Ghost and this is the concept of the
Trinity that has been developed after
the council and I see I mean it was
around but that's when they solidified
it you're talking about many councils
that have taken place to reach what
theologically people believe in
Christianity today and I encourage
people to do a quick research just a
quick research all the Christian
councils and what were the issues that
were discussed it's not a major issue
yeah because if you break it down what
do you mean extension of the journey
because if if we're talking about modern
day Christianity that's what it is uh
crucifixion Trinity sorry is Akon saying
I mean he made a mistake hopefully he'll
take this as a uh as something good that
we're helping him out here so next time
he can give better dawa and do it
properly
um inshallah and from here so if you're
saying if you're breaking this down so
what is it it's an extension off now
this modern day Christianity that we
have of crucifixion of Trinity yes I
mean if you if you look uh deeper into
the beginnings right or what about is it
what happened because at the time of
Jesus there was no Christianity there
was no Christianity Jesus was ethnically
a Jew ethnically okay and it's a lot of
Jews also sometimes they don't tell you
that Judaism is you know they made into
religion they're just ethnically Jews
like Arabs Arab is not a religion
you have Arabs you have Jews you have
different ethnicities
you know we have it's not a religion the
the followers of Moses what we call Beni
Israel
and coming from Israel from Jacob yes
Prophet Jacob uh they're Muslim they
were Muslim as long as they followed
Prophet Moses correctly s so he was on
the straight line right it was one of
those stations people you gotta when
people hear the definition then it makes
sense because the mission to God so if
you say it like that they were once who
did submission to the will of God
exactly now you understand followed what
the prophet that was at that time I.E
Moses at the time brought the details
Moses Aaron Prophet Aaron and you know
uh prophets that came in that line of
prophets they brought the law they
worshiped only one God if you follow it
them you were a submitter I.E a Muslim
translation because people get caught up
in semantics yeah in words right
translations so when you explain it
people be like oh but it doesn't make
sense but it's a submission you mean
you're following and you're obeying God
right so those who follow Jesus were
Muslim I.E submission in submission and
those fall Abraham it's all that's
what's beautiful about
submission about Islam right it's not an
ethnicity it is a concept anyone who
just Ponders a little bit over this
point they will say that it makes sense
you don't have to agree with me but
don't tell me that doesn't make sense
it's like if you take a modern day word
they might have not heard but the
concept they were human right they were
human right exactly right they were
Muslim because Muslim is one same thing
like a human if you define human say
okay that fits same thing here right
Muslim is one who submits his or her
will to the one Creator that's it and uh
when speaking to someone like Dr Gerald
Dirks and others these were big people
in the church Deacon you know doctors
and Divinity and whatnot and then they
go and look at some of these words they
go into their make and the Greek what
they find is that this and you've I
think also pointed this out before many
people have studied this they've said
that even those Christians at the time
this was something that a label that was
put upon them and then there was people
of the Sunnah they were people of the
way they were people who were trying
just just like we have the sun of the
way people who are many original people
who are crying trying to be christ-like
just like we try to follow the way the
Sunnah they have people who are trying
to follow the way of Jesus of pure
monotheism but then you had the fight
and then the people who believed in the
unitarians like the bosnians people from
my neck of the woods there right
hungarians hungarians these were people
who are monotheists till today there's
huge numbers there's huge numbers yeah
so those are then you had those people
who try to be christ-like who really try
not worshiping Jesus but worshiping the
God Jesus worship and then when Islam
comes to fit like a glove and they
accepted the final messenger that's
right Prophet Muhammad yeah peace be
upon them all yeah before I go on there
was one thing that he said is very
correct that we believe in Jesus we love
Jesus as a mighty messenger this is a
correct statement that Akon made we want
to elaborate on that no doubt no doubt
Jesus
Aisa
right is is a a very important one of
the five strong prophets that were sent
they were sent to mankind so he's not
just any Prophet he's a special Prophet
that came and he is the one look at the
fairness I want people to just please
please just pay attention
just ponder over this if you don't take
anything from this podcast take this one
part yeah do you think
if Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
is
let's say how you say that he's not a
prophet okay some people say amazing
system yes everything
wow the Quran makes sense this book is
amazing what you guys are saying cool
but you know I don't know Prophet
Muhammad
wouldn't it make sense
to try to focus people towards you if
you're the prophet call people towards
you to for the promise of Salvation
everything whatever
everything to be focused on you
but God says
he doesn't speak from his own desire
pay attention
so Prophet Muhammad said that the one
who's coming back
is Jesus not him
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him is
dead
and he's buried in Medina
you can go and see his grave
yet the one who was saved and raised and
he will I mean race to the heavens and
he'll come back
okay to fight the
uh the gel or the Antichrist is Prophet
Jesus now imagine
Prophet Mama could have said no I'm
coming back I'm gonna be resurrected
I'll be the one in the center I'll be no
he said why
he died No One's Gonna check it after
you know it's because this is he was
truthful
because it was not about him it's about
what God Said
it's about what is the truth if I want
to make things about me about my
religion my way I'll make sure that's
all about me that's how it is human
beings are self-centered
right if I'm if I'm doing you're the
host of the show okay you invite me on
but it's about you're running this show
people it's about them Akon his music is
about him
Paul whatever it's about him everything
is about them when they portraying and
they're selling something they're
marketing something look at Prof mama
foreign he said Jesus come back look how
important is the second coming of Jesus
is going to be he's gonna be the one who
kills the Antichrist he's gonna be the
one who leads the Muslims at that time
this is I want them to really think
about the honesty and the truthfulness
of prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
I really want them to ponder about this
absolutely the last and final messenger
sent to mankind taking nothing away from
Jesus but he was sent out his time
that's it for the people at that time
and you can't be a Muslim unless you
love and believe in Jesus you cannot be
a Muslim you cannot even because I
believe in Muhammad peace be upon him
but I don't believe me just you are not
a Muslim yeah what do you mean but
Muhammad peace be upon the one he's the
one no you cannot be Muslim we all have
different cultures we always speak
different languages but I would be born
in different places but at the end of
the day he all he made sure that no
matter what circumstance or area or
religion that you follow that there was
always the one God at the top of the
ladder now this is religion and always
never will forget this
look at it like a navigation
right
we all go into the same place but
there's different directions to get
there
so I can't look at you and say okay
because you're Jewish that
okay you're not spiritually sown or
you're not going to heaven or whatever
place that is or because you're Buddhist
so because of whatever at the end of the
day we all have this one thing that we
all follow that there's the most high
right there's a God that we you know
that we give praises to and he's the
reason why we want to become better for
everyone else to better
ourselves in the eyes of his
and I'll ask even if it's yourself even
if you believe that I'm God
it's okay because in actuality we are
Gods we create life we whatever and if
you want to be better for yourself and
do the right thing so you can feel good
about yourself then so be it but God is
more of an energy more of a spirit all
right it's to Enlighten you to want to
be better for yourself and everybody
else that's attached to you people
hearing say hear you saying some stuff
in Arabic you've actually you're fluent
in Arabic uh you read the Quran in
Arabic you've been studying uh Islam for
you got a masters in theology
yeah I'm working on a master's
um Counseling in theology in the
counseling but uh Bachelors I believe in
Islam Islamic Studies so um
you were saying some things in in Arabic
when you heard him say I seek refuge in
Allah for one is saying this is
okay let's check and we cannot I know
he's he claims to be a Muslim
but actually to be honest he's not a
Muslim by what he's saying and I know
people are going to get upset what I say
but because he said basically you can
claim to be a God you are a God in a
sense this is not this is and there's
been
um certain Muslim sex so-called Muslims
but they're not Muslims who claim some
of these questions the Nation of Islam
you got the Five Percenters before that
the concept of that God is in you and
you are you know you're in God and all
that IBN Arabi had some weird you know
Concepts like that and I know people
don't like this I don't we don't we
don't we shouldn't make tick fear on
people right but this is blatant Shook
and someone says that this takes them
out of the follow of Islam so I know
people are going to get sad but this guy
is not a Muslim you know and I'm
responsible for what I say I don't have
a problem to say that you know because I
know sometimes we play we're just like
we're cool he's cool this and that he
said basically that
first of all the mistake is he said
we'll all have the same path I cannot
tell you not gonna no if you're not
following the correct path guess what we
don't have the same path you're now
going to heaven I don't even know if I'm
going to heaven bro I mean at some point
because I'm a Muslim because
if I die upon this I will go to heaven
yes
but I might still have some time to
serve to for my sins I pray and I hope
that I don't but look at the arrogance
of someone to say that we're all going
to Heaven There is one God what what
concept you can just claim that the
concept of God that Buddhism or Hindus
have is the same as the pure monotheism
that a Muslim has no this is this is
intellectually
um is dishonest
right this is ignorant
it's not because I claim it's not about
me I I go and go and read the book
it's not about me
it's not that I had the audacity to say
here in this this seat and make that
claim
this is by
what the prophet saw anyone who
Associated partners with God
meaning forbidden
anyone who says this
has so it's not me I'm just conveying
the message yeah so people don't get
upset that rather Gabriel Roma is making
Tech fear but indeed claiming that we
are gods and in some Highway we have
this is horrible this is what's the cut
what are we I mean is this something now
that if he's uh what does Akon need to
do now I mean if he hears this he
basically if he hears that he's saying
I'm saying this metaphorically I don't
mean this that what do you what do we
what he does he's explaining what he
means yeah he's explaining the concept
first of all in having the the idea that
everyone's going to heaven and everyone
believes in one God so all the same
basically just different stories that is
his self [__] well right away it comes
to mind is
exactly this is the original language
and Allah is saying that whoever chooses
away other than then submission is
running to the Creator Islam exactly
never will it be and look at this very
simple never will be acceptable and in
the Hereafter they'll be among the loot
this is clear and then there's another
verse that comes to mind in the Dina in
Allah
the only way of life meaning the only
way you can get to Paradise is not all
roads lead to Rome it's through
submission and surrender not to a human
being Trinity is to surrender pure
monotheism so he's made up his own
religion basically and this is the
danger and this is how other religions
have come about a major imagine now some
people are going to have akonism or
something like that they're going to say
this is the correct understanding
and this is uh this is wrong
um
just what he said is it is it good
enough can people see why we're
discussing this because I hope they do
this is important now I hope they do uh
Corrections too because see in the in
the Free World today everyone says that
we're all the same we're all going the
same place okay let's test this theory
if you guys think really believe they're
all going to the same place by Falling
all this okay so how about we just all
fall Islam because it all leads to the
same place ain't it so let's just all
fall Islam it's the purest the cleanest
it's got the most academic uh evidence
for it historical evidence let's just
all fall Islam if you really let's all
just follow Islam
people are not going to want to do that
isn't it so actually you know this is
just a uh uh and I don't want people the
wrong impression or wrong idea this is
out of we're saying is out of the love
yeah we care for you if not you know but
but this is messed up sorry yeah like
it's really bad you know to believe that
you claim to be God or that God is
inside of you
this is um if the Christian is not going
to agree with him yeah because there's
contradictory beliefs here because even
even though we can work together on many
things the sexualization of children and
you know the the family Decay and we're
come together with uh with Christians
and other people of other faith we could
do that right yeah but now we can get
the elephant out of the room and say
look you and I've sat with you know
friends of mine from from a long time
ago I said okay let's get telephoto room
we agree you believe I'm going to hell
if I don't believe that Jesus that's
what I believe yeah but I do believe in
Jesus but it's just not that he's a God
or a little son of God so then we get
into a discussion but I respect you that
you you love me that much you claim to
love me that you're going to tell me the
truth rather than me believing you know
you you want me to to understand and
then I tell you the same thing there's a
clear Hadith where the Prophet Muhammad
didn't he say he said anyone who hears
of me right and doesn't accept me as the
final messenger so you hear the evidence
it's been laid out not the distorted
stuff from CNN Fox right it's been made
clear like you're hearing it now and you
reject him he there's a clear statement
from what did he say that they'll be
here you're done you're going to hell
that's I mean it's sensitive for a lot
of a lot of people but this is
we want you we want you to to at least I
think people respect that too yeah at
least take the time to to do something
now we can talk now we got this out of
the way let's work together on many uh
different platforms on things that are
that we agree on we can agree on yeah
yeah you know and there's a lot of
things we have in common no doubt yeah
no doubt but this is uh this this is a a
major more than a blunder okay
Define the Shirk is setting up Rivals
Partners this is the unforgivable
um sin that if someone dies so he's
saying that we don't believe Jesus Is
God then he turns and says well we are
gods in a way so what you're doing so
you don't believe Jesus God who's much
better than you he said that's what we
believe we don't believe Jesus Is God
and then he goes and turns to him says
well you know in a way we are gods and
we are gods and what you're doing what
can he say like if he's saying I don't
mean it like that is there a contest
well first of all it's not about you
know why I didn't mean it because your
words mean something they matter
like you can't say talak and say I
didn't mean it yeah I didn't mean it
right you can't say I divorced him that
I didn't mean well you can't stay heavy
in Islam yeah I'm gonna kill you but
then oh I I didn't mean to lock you up
they lock you up you can't the police
come that's good the police coming you
just said no you take it back I was just
joking yeah so we know God has given us
a rationale and reason things matter
don't worry don't joke with it this is
not a joke I would advise him to say
and to desist from every kind and to
study actually if he reads the Quran I
mean this is a good advice this is easy
you say it every day if you're praying
five times a day if you're not just in
Juma almost even if you're just going
Juma you're saying the shahada say it
again and now make this correction
meaning like repent say okay this is
wrong they can't fix it this is what you
need to do and see the thing is
I can almost guarantee that he doesn't
read the Quran with understanding like a
translation at least
right because in the Quran you have all
this what we're talking by the way
people you know this is not me and you
talking we're taking these and giving
evidences you're quoting I'm quoting
from the Quran so don't think that it's
like two of us are sitting here and just
pointing fingers we're just Messengers
right after the there's no more traffic
smashability you know I cannot say this
like we want him to fix himself
but the problem is you know with the
this kind of lifestyle and you know
people just mess around man
yeah you can program with all these
rappers and everyone's thinking they're
God they're my God semi God all this
stuff and that Creeps in your bit your
program you get hit with these because
these spiritual diseases you're an idol
right everyone's so centered towards you
where this
ego takes hold the few
and now you start seeing dangerous
things like that like what's his name
Keanu when he said I am a God who said
that Johnny West right Kanye West Kanye
West and then he walked into a pool and
smashed his head in it
so Kanye West he also said yeah he says
God right yeah and then he walked into a
pool but according to the Bible he
should be then according to the Bible
he's not a Christian he's not a
Christian he left Christian and he
apostrated from Christianity
by that statement yeah we're playing
with these right according to
Christianity you know yeah and then he
again Kanye West ends up hitting his
head it's on it's on YouTube
I feel bad for the guy man yeah you know
may God help him and guide him I mean I
mean I want the best for everybody this
is um not on any malicious attempts that
we have here trying to put someone down
I don't know yeah we're just oh but this
is uh this is some especially with the
youth when they hear someone like this
saying these things and then next you
know you got kids mimicking because they
mimic they see you and they start
thinking yeah I'm a God you're a God
we're all God you can't say this is
right like you said this is and we live
on tawheed pure monotheism and and that
monotheism is what's going to with our
with
um our living a morally upright life
we're human beings we do good deeds but
it's not by our Good Deeds it's by God's
grace and mercy we're all Sinners yeah
we're all we have so many mistakes and
all it's sometimes you know we know
ourselves we know we're we're not
sitting here being all Godly and think
we're all good may Allah and you cover
our mistakes and our sins you know we're
not worthy of that but his Mercy is so
great
that we hope that he'll accept us you
know this is what we hope for I mean
let's uh let's continue on great advice
for Akon God willing anybody else who's
fallen into that my God Almighty I'll
protect us from from this and may you
take the advice
and see the good that we're trying to
deliver to him and others
and that tells you everything because we
know man didn't create that
okay let's say an alien created that
okay who created the alien
like the big bang thing is like the
whole thing but like right who pushed
the [__] button right yeah let me
just from nothingness there was this
there was something something happened
thank you it's impossible bro how did
that something that's even be created
right like whenever you in doubt just
think about that and it'll bring you all
the way back again because you can't
explain that I
I think though a part of the reason why
people may land on God or want to
believe that something did start from
nothing is because we want explanations
our species wants answers
we're here what we're doing that's it's
really Play-Doh
what are we doing here how do we get it
but that's what I'm saying humans we're
natural we're nosy creatures
and and I'm happy to see these kind of
conversations because people are talking
about this that and the other but invite
us to the conversations invite them with
some sort of conversations people of
knowledge you know people who are also
loving to talk about these things you
know Scholars of Islam and whatnot and
others you know like yourself and
whatnot to come and sit and have these
proper because there's a lot of
questions here some some and I like the
the points he's making you know who
pushed the button who started everything
right but then the one thing about the
the faith in Islam is not Blind Faith
yeah no doubt I mean yeah I'm not a
scholar so they should invite the
scholars I think we have some good
Scholars that could answer their
questions and but see that's the thing
it's such a disconnect between these
Youth and the scholars sadly and
hopefully we that's what we're trying to
do I guess bridge that we try to bridge
that Gap yes yeah now
it's Faith 100 you have
those who believe in the Unseen
but to reach that level there's always
some
connection
and God has made it quite simple it's
not so complicated because he has given
us the ability to observe and to reason
and to understand
and
people say well he says we want
explanations yeah exactly but there's a
difference between explanation and
evidence
right people can explain things as much
as they want people will be like that's
a good explanation but do I really is
that an Evidence do I believe
why God the almighty when he created
everything and he has sent his
Messengers
and his message he has given evidence
it's simple I think it's very simple
because see people are at different
levels of comprehension and
rationale you got very Advanced people
academics phds research evidence-based
scientific method and you got your
typical dishwasher and street sweeper
who is very simple right
both have a brain
but they both have the ability to
observe when you read through the Quran
Allah God
the Almighty is focusing people to use
observation to look around specifically
in creation and in themselves as well
Allah say look around
and today in the morning
I was just looking at a video of a
statement
and he said
that people want the existence of you
know of God in the creation of the
heavens and the stars and the moon which
is really amazing if you think about it
just to study that just to look at
just sunrise and sunset
the Perfection of that system
how it changes with the season how at
some points is constant different parts
of the world is different just that that
complexity of that system there's no way
be it dishwasher or PhD candidate or
doctor they're both gonna be like man
there's no way that this is just
something happened and I want some
explanation right away you will know
that there is a creator
come on
if you're honest enough
you will know
there's a Creator just by observing that
so Imam Shafi said forget about that he
said
for me it's just in the leaf
of of a the dude tree
he said he said why he said look at it
he said the cow will eat it
and pure milk will come out of it
right
and then he said the bee will take from
its pollen and that amazing honey will
come out of it
and then he said that the uh the um
I guess uh the warm that becomes you
know into whether you take the uh this
um
what is it the uh
the material that you make clothes from
yes right from the worms you know he's
like it will eat it and it will give you
um the string you know I don't know what
it's called I forget forgive me
he said look at that they're all eating
the same leaf and look what you're
getting out of it oh and uh
the deer will eat it and out of the deer
you'll make musk pure Musk
they're all eating the same look at look
at that system they're all eating the
same thing processing the same thing
yeah look at it pure
milk pure honey Pure misk or a perfume
and the string that you make clothes
from
right amazing he said just from there
you can know that there's a Creator just
from the simple observations subhanallah
that's a whole different discussion we
can go down how people got to the state
of just disbelief in something that just
so obvious and then and then giving
people who almost
um credibility and people think that
they're intelligent coming from a state
of Academia or whatnot because you have
a lot of academics and others I mean it
shows that you can be the dumbest person
Smart in many different facets but you
can be almost like uh just crippled in
this area of common sense you know to
deny when the signs are all around you I
don't think it's being dumb I think as a
prophet saws said that is it's arrogance
arrogance denying the truth so it's just
that's that that's that the kibber now
that arrogance now you're too too proud
too arrogant to go ahead and and that's
why um
with the Academia
it was in 2000 and early 2000 Steinberg
or whatever his name is he had that
documentary intelligence expelled uh no
intelligence allowed yes right and he
went and researched this whole Mafia in
Academia the expel uh creationists right
who through their studies
of the universe or whatever size they
were in they said look we can go with
this our Darwin is we have to believe
that there's a Creator it's because all
the evidence is pointing that way so
they lost their funding they got kicked
out of the academic circles it was like
a mafia so that that's really and I
point that documentary because it shows
like it's a mirage that's set up like oh
if you're smart you're intelligent that
now you deny no right there's actually
many of these academics Academia that
they come to the conclusion exactly but
they're shut down they're blacklisted
exactly by the uh Mafia yeah they lose
everything yeah and then they've had
studied Oxford study and others that now
you know multi-million dollar studies
that confirmed that innate doesn't
innate nature to believe right in the
higher being wired you're wired You've
Got The God Spot they call it right
so um this is uh really profound and
just one last thing here Islam provides
all the evidence everything you need to
know that it is from The Troop but the
faith comes in in the Unseen now you
don't see a lot of details after that
there's a lot of details right 100 so
the driving force it gets you there but
now there's some things you have to have
faith you got to fit you can't see the
Hellfire you can't see Paradise exactly
you can't you're the Angels you can't
see the Angels you're not seeing you're
the prophets in this life you can't see
your creator 100 yeah 100
um and then people
um yeah this is some really good things
for people to contemplate and think
about we're almost done let's uh
continue on
like loan despair void of of that
purpose and magic in life is is it would
make me crazy yeah but but there's also
I think Beauty in that if you can find
it we're we're impossible humans are
impossible we're on this planet as far
as we know we're the only intelligent
species as far as we can see and we
can't explain it we don't know what
we're doing here and so there's oh a
reason to be depressed about that but
also there's a reason to go dance
again that's incredibly cool
he said a few things where the only
intelligent species I want I want you to
touch upon that and then the other thing
that we don't know what we're doing here
why are we here pretty much right
so obviously we're not the only ones
because God did create What's called the
Jinn I thought about that exactly right
exactly now they're they're reason and
rationale are not exactly like ours
we're Superior and we've been given
certain knowledge and that is clearly
evident from what God has told us and
however
um
purpose wise we don't know what we're
doing of course we know exactly what
we're doing that's the whole point
to discover what you need to do and to
try to do it you live your life in
trying to do it
no one can claim that we're doing
amazing or perfect some people are
better
some people are not so better
if you're Allah as much as you can do
your best right now are we comparing
people who now have the guidance versus
those who don't right so the people are
having the guidance even those are not
you know perfect right we're just
struggling we're trying we're trying to
do the best
but at least you know the direction but
imagine if you don't have Islam if you
don't have Islam you're like you're lost
okay so now he's talking from that
perspective I think so I think a lot of
and this ties into something I'm very
passionate about mental health yeah I
think a lot of the depression anxiety is
just that void of not knowing your
purpose as you said that's a good
analysis so people fill it up with
alcohol drugs sex this that
because there's an existential crisis
that has hit Humanity
you don't know what your purpose is
yeah you might do Sports you might do a
podcast you might this but these are
very temporary then you get bored again
you're like okay what's next that's why
ethics and morality change so much
because people are chasing the new hit
because it's not enough
but when you have your true purpose you
understand that you're supposed to be
worshiping your Creator and you're
supposed to spread this message
then this satisfies that existential
void it's going to be always work to be
done
but I think most people are depressed
today because of this their souls
are not understanding they're not in
in sync with that fitra with the purpose
that God created for and the souls are
screaming out of pain
and this is what depression is Logan's a
good example of somebody who was brought
up in a Christian household but things
just don't make sense doesn't add up the
answers aren't not there right uh he
would qualify great for many people who
go through the same thing I've
interviewed you know hundreds of them
you're one of them you're born in a
Christian household back this is not to
put down anybody from any other religion
but this is just obvious fact you also
you were getting answers to your
questions you were talking to the higher
up so I remember correctly this down the
other Islam had the answers If Logan
comes and with an open heart open mind
looks at Islam objectively he's looking
for the TR if he's looking sincerely
asking the Creator for guidance you
think he'll find what you found in Islam
I think if he's sincere he's sincere no
doubt about it no doubt about it I don't
I I often think about that I think
because when you look at many of the the
man-made religions and you look what
they call you to answer the words to
Pagan worship the self worship all this
stuff and when you look at Islam I don't
think any intelligent human being who
doesn't have this arrogance right who's
you're yearning inside and he's asking
the Creator guide me I want to know why
I'm here that the Creator wouldn't guide
him I think you have to take one reminds
me sorry reminds me if you take one step
God take 10 towards you the head
according to Hadith right so you come
walking God will come Allah will come
running is this correct 100 I remember
earlier when I was
looking into Islam
and just look him back at the the first
stage in my life
I was arrogant because I used to fight
with the Muslims and they would give me
explanations and I would but I couldn't
see it were you a islamophobe I did not
like Islam because that's how we were
raised in Romania that's why I asked
because many Romanians and others even
people in the area in the Balkans they
don't there's they're just naturally
they're right born and bred like almost
islamable but I remember the guys who
told me about Islam they told me the
same things because Islam is not like
complicated it's not like some guy's
gonna tell you one thing another guy's
gonna tell you something else it's the
same thing arm people from that area
more hard-headed more like silver they
are okay but the weird thing is I think
due to the fact that I was arrogant I
couldn't see it
however when I started going through a
depression and some problems my mind
opened up and I was humbled so now when
the Bosnian brother talked to me I saw
it you know what I mean it's because I
was humbled
that arrogance was taken away from
because I was in depression
all that Macho cool thing that I had
before fighting with them so you guys
Muslims this and yeah what is this Islam
even though at the time what Islam is
God one God Islam is all prophets had
the same message the same thing
I couldn't see it yeah when I was
humbled and I was pretty much on my
knees and suffering at that time my ears
and my mind was too and I was like okay
makes sense big difference big
difference so uh Logan Paul and we we
covered that there is another creation
people call it the spirit world and
whatnot the Gin right and then also this
part about a lot of people get it like
they don't get this point so because
Aladdin and the Ginny yeah and all that
they're like what is that right I really
it explains so many things in this world
so many UFOs I'm trying to fight who can
we say unidentified flying objects
possession mental health issues uh
haunted uh houses Cemetery all that's
explained by this belief that we have in
the yeah don't don't look at a lot in
the Lambda forget this forget about
Disney World yeah okay the last thing
that they talked about and I want to
touch upon because it has me go back
when we talked about this was Michael
Jackson okay you remember yeah yeah yeah
Akon was mentioning uh some stories
about Michael Jackson and Michael
Jackson when we talked we spoke about
him last time bring us up to speed what
happened with Michael Jackson towards
the end of his life you mentioned you
had an inside source or something
Jackson yeah so some people have been
saying that someone said this and no
it's not real and another brother I'm
not gonna name them I don't want to get
into any discussions fights I'm just
giving you what I know okay so they're
saying no brother Gabriel wrong Michael
Jackson never became Muslim also they
said we spoke to I don't know who and he
said you're wrong and he never became
Muslim and whatever right
so again I'm gonna repeat the issue the
story right and I'm not gonna name the
brother even though I know his name
and I he was my neighbor when I was in
Abu Dhabi
and he was basically working with
Michael Jackson's brother Jermaine
Jackson yeah and he would come every
like two months because basically he was
going to Africa and doing these
documentaries he was the cameraman
okay and he told me look we keep it on
the hush but he became Muslim and I know
like I'm with Jermaine like I know he
became the guy so this is the cameraman
of Jermaine Jackson who was your
neighbor in Abu Dhabi yes exactly
getting this information you'll be going
working two three months with German he
will come back to Abu Dhabi because his
wife was a teacher and his son was there
sometimes my wife would a babysitter uh
her son and they'll play my kids and
yeah he's like we know he became Muslim
alhamdulillah you know for sure 100
that's what he told me I believed him
because he was working with Jermaine but
they said we keep it on on the low I
mean why am I saying it because I know
he didn't tell me don't tell anyone but
he said we just keep it on the Law
whatever that's the way it is
but this is what he has told me I
believe him and I hope not because he
was like come on let's be honest you
know people they love they liked Michael
Jackson you know right uh I feel I felt
he got dealt a very bad hand at the end
and what people start saying some things
came out after that that yeah he got set
up even that guy stuff all I think he
committed suicide or something
the young boy that you know his parents
were trying to get to say things that he
did things to him and all that I don't
know I think that's what happened he was
in huge depression the way I was
analyzing it I was thinking like hey you
know I mean you know you never know I
mean did Allah uh the almighty guide him
at the end at the end now before because
a lot of times people will come to Islam
they'll have that Awakening moment but
then they fall in back into all of the
trips and tracks of the Dunya and that
lifestyle it took to shahada and then
Allah took him because we know when
someone comes into Islam all their
previous sins like a newborn babies no I
don't I don't know personally I believe
it but Alana's best personally thought
the brother told me he was very reliable
brother hard-working good family
Jermaine Jackson is definitely we know
he's also he's a Muslim you know what
I'm saying yeah so this is his brother
Michael Jackson and this is you're
getting it from the cameraman so
all right so we covered a lot here I'm
gonna cover it a lot um you also you
before we conclude talk to us about
um you you're helping to develop uh what
motivated you to you're helping to
develop high value men right with uh
these uh courses trainings that you do
let's talk a little bit about that right
so we have the Muslim Alpha Man course
again people get caught on the semantics
please guys leave the semantics alone
it's just like
is it the dean show is
you know it's been going on for about 18
years mashallah you know alone so
it's helping men to re-establish their
masculine to be men the way Allah
created us on the Natural Way men or men
women are women women are not men men
are not women women cannot do what men
do men you know cannot do what women do
we can do certain things what are you
talking about brother we're living at
the time of uh how many 100 plus genders
no way no way let's let's just use the
head that God gave us it's the easiest
most clear things most evident thing
okay so in these courses we help men to
change their mindset to come back to the
fitra to build value in themselves to
get closer to their creator and to work
on themselves their personal development
their physical spiritual emotional
development psychological psychiatric
you know ability cognition
um how to just become a better man who
can contribute see it's not just
building value and just keeping it to
yourself is what you can do to spread
the message of Islam to have a purpose
that's what the Muslim Alpha Man focuses
on gives men a purpose changes their
mindset wherever you are you don't have
to have a Bugatti you have to have beat
top G and all that right there's so much
talk about masculinity right now
actually when we start talking about
these things and we're working and doing
these things because we noticed that
young children young boys in Muslim
countries they lost their their
understanding of what it is it it is to
be a man
this whole talk of red pill it was not
even existent yet
okay it was not even existing it's not
because I said it's because when you
look at how the processing was Howard
the sahaba they were real men
and their women were real women
okay and people try to use different
exceptions here and there yesterday I
was talking to the brothers you know was
the typical Muslim feminist objection
how was the was the uh you know business
woman right I'm like okay you want to be
like Khadijah because you know they
quote that right so you find all the
tick tocks all the Hadith I'm the
businesswoman under this meaning I can
go outside I can do whatever I want I
can put makeup I can be a you know I can
leave the house I don't need to listen
to any man I'm independent woman
it's rubbish this doesn't exist
never raised her voice to the process
and therefore Allah sent salaam to him
through the angel specifically for her
yes right because she never raised her
voice never imaginary she wasn't
belligerent she wasn't like that you
know so if you want to be like your
argumentative no no I'm gonna say one
thing they say no and that's why Allah
gave her special place in Jannah where
there's no loud noises
because she never raised her voice to
the process that's a really powerful
point so if you want to take this is the
this is the one of the mothers of the
believer that's it the example exciting
her then okay be like okay so start
taking these notes now how she what got
her that honor and that Allah sent now
exactly wow and the next point is she
never herself gone and did all these
things because that's how she married
the processant because she hired him was
she shaking hands but she was hiring men
she was she hired them and the prophet
saws would go and do things things and
another man other men would basically
run the errands for her so she didn't
have uh sit Downs not like face to face
with with men not like just mixing going
all this putting stuff pushing shoving
talking loud being all out there doing
stuff she would she had what's called
Haya or this this bashfulness right so
let's look into these details these are
facts people can go check ups right and
I'll throw a curveball in the end if you
want to be like okay then start cashing
out your bank account sister because
she spent all her money on the Prof
sauce yeah everything every single Cent
on him when the Muslims got boycotted
everything she had
she spent it on the processarily because
he was a high value man she believed in
his mission would not be someone who's
like sleeping till 11 and doing nothing
no Mission or nothing just yeah I'm the
man come on give me the money no
he was a man on a mission and she found
so much value in him that she put
everything
so if you want to be like Khadija my
sisters let's start
but of course A real man who's on a
mission you know not some
um sorry any loser who's sleeping all
the time and he's uh I don't know what
to do I'm depressed I'm lost you know
well I help the brothers you know I mean
we have some brothers who need support
yeah
but so that's my little curveball for
the for the feminist Muslims
uh so this is uh developing men at a
time where people are
in a state of confusion
not knowing uh yeah so this course in
Charlotte is focused on that we do also
some practical things we go like horse
riding we do some MMA some you know Jiu
Jitsu we just had some nice uh
here at resovich uh you know Academy
here mashallah with some nice uh some
nice rolling about about 15 rounds
mashallah so we encourage men to to be
to be strong men have to be strong yet
merciful
have limits
yet kind
right be assertive yet loving and
passionate right you see the balance
yeah this is a real man right to have a
courage
yet no no arrogance right these These
are the
see fat or the attributes of real men
not that I say because when we look and
study again the prophet saws
specifically you'll find these in him so
work on that and mental health
counseling getting the man to get out of
their mind where they're always just
stuck there right stuck right be brave
who cares if people criticize you
as Allah they do not fear the blame of
the blamers right do not fear people as
long as you are trying to do your best
you gotta make mistakes I guarantee you
you'll make mistakes
and that's why a lot of people are in
this limbo because like what if I make a
mistake of course you're going to maybe
was corrected by Allah
all right the process correct in the
Quran and it's there till the day of
judgment for everyone to read and he was
corrected who are you not to make you're
gonna make mistake but don't stop don't
stop keep pushing a woman is not because
we are making mistakes as men and we
have problems we should recognize that
we have a lot of issues as men a lot of
weaknesses
but guess what that doesn't justify now
for them to become men and to take our
positions because they're not created
to do that they cannot do it
they cannot do it and if they try to do
it the process them said already that
it's going to be a failing system where
people don't like it they like it they
try to explain that's what the process
and said so work towards that
Let's help man and help women to be
women this is the beauty this is the
amazing thing
the greatest Scholars and Warriors of
this ummah have come from a woman look
at the Great Value and that Allah has
given women yet the society is
convincing that you're a slave and some
maid and you should be ashamed yourself
and you should be a man that's when
you're going to get your real value but
I thought you hate men it's but you want
to be a man look at the contradiction
and the confusion
where can people if they want to get
more information right so
muslimalpha.com on all my videos on you
know I just type Gabriel Romani and
Google you find my social media the
links are always there
and you can sign up alhamdulillah thank
you brother thank you again as always to
have you uh always here with uh with us
brothers and sisters so we got roof
number one completed as you've seen
alhamdulillah
this Uma project is garnering so much
support
[Music]
remember there are five buildings here
and next is building number two the roof
needs to be replaced that's where the
Masjid will be
quite a walk it's like a block yes
here yeah what's your uh
[Music]
Allah
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedenshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum